A responsive website, changes based
on the characteristics of the device.
This means, that your responsive site,
needs to apply different styles,
for different devices.
There are few ways to
selectively apply CSS.
The easiest, is with media queries.
Media queries, provide easy logic for
applying different styles depending
on device characteristics.
Like its width, height,
or device pixel ratio.
You can change everything,
from background images to restructuring
the site's layout and even more.
Adding responsive styles is easy.
Simply include an additional style
sheet in your page, with a media query.
Let me show you how to write one.